you take care of the suit what I'll take
care of the music
[Music]
hi everyone its Charlie this is gonna be
my spider-man far from home Easter eggs
video hopefully you've had a chance to
see the movie we're doing an IMAX ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
spider-man moment on the video so
obviously a spoiler warning if you have
not seen spider-man far from home yet
because we'd be talking about everything
that happens during the movie there's so
many Easter eggs I tried to restrict
this to like the top 50 just to keep the
video from turning into an hour long
starting at the beginning the Columbia
logo actually matches to the statue that
they're driving by on their way to the
town in Mexico to investigate the
Sandman attack they do the exact same
thing with the Indiana Jones movies
starting with Raiders of the Lost Ark
matching the logo to the opening shot of
the movie when they drive into the
center of town there's a bucket that
reads 78 on it which is an Easter Egg
for the 1978 amazing spider-man TV
series it only ran for a couple seasons
it was a fairly low-budget so it was
very friendly neighborhood spider-man
and service of that so he was taking
down street-level villains instead of
doing really huge sinister six level
stuff
[Music]
they walked past a license plate that
reads 463 which is the date of the first
appearance of Sandman in the comics
amazing spider-man number four in 1963
every time one of the elementals
appeared there was a license plate or a
number in the background of their first
appearance in the comics the elementals
were basically spider-man villains
albeit in slightly different form they
me Mysterio for the first time he's the
Quentin Beck version of the character
the first version from the comics who
debuted during amazing spider-man number
13 and the story of Mysterio during the
movie was basically a highlight reel for
that very first appearance he shows up
pretending to be a hero
he goes to jejune of jameson at the
Daily Bugle and says that spider-man is
a villain like he does at the end of the
movie and says that I'll catch him on
live TV everyone will think that I'm the
hero the changes they made to that story
are that in the comics the final battle
took place on the Brooklyn Bridge
instead of the London Tower Bridge like
the movie and then obviously there are a
couple minor changes about how his
character works what his backstory is he
used to work for Tony Stark at Stark
Industries Quentin Beck from the comics
was a special-effects wizard but Quentin
Beck in the movie is also a specialist
with Holograms so they tried to be as
true to his comic book origin as
possible while at the same time sort of
bringing everything back to the Iron Man
character
Captain America Civil War with respect
to Quentin Beck's character Mysterio in
the MCU is actually the person while
working for Tony Stark that invented the
be AR effing technology in the reason
why he's revolting against Iron Man in
developing this whole big plot during
the movie is because he was so pissed
off at Iron Man calling his life's work
barf and then firing him when he claimed
that Quentin Beck was unstable but there
were easter eggs going all the way back
to the first Iron Man film with some of
the people on Quentin Beck's team you
may have recognized Peter Billingsley
from the first Iron Man film he's the
one that gets yelled at by Obadiah Stane
because he's not as smart as Tony Stark
with a box of scraps the name of his
character during that is William Ginter
Reba he escapes at the end of the film
with the thumb drive with all the data
and the renders of Mysterio so it's
always possible if they really want to
bring Mysterio back in the Quentin Beck
Mysterio really did die at the end of
the film as he made Peter believe still
a lot of theories about how he could
have survived they could do the second
version of Mysterio just like a lot of
the other sinister six characters the
mantle of Mysterio gets passed down
through the comics they opened the movie
with that really bad version of a high
school and news broadcast in a memorial
that one of their friends put together
to Whitney Houston's I will always love
you
they made it really bad on purpose
they're stealing images from Getty
that's why they have all the watermarks
on the Getty Images they cropped are the
photos pretty poorly but they say
goodbye to a lot of heroes you notice
the Captain America's picture appears
during that memorial so it seems like
the world thinks the Captain America
died at the end of Avengers endgame
instead of going back in time and living
with Peggy Carter you may also recognize
some of the stock pictures that they
used the one for Iron Man was a picture
that was used during a big presentation
honoring Tony Stark during the original
Iron Man movie - the picture itself also
foreshadows some of the plot of the
movie it's very meta because it's him
behind all these weapons of mass
destruction that he used to create he
was a weapons manufacturer and there's a
big MacGuffin during the movie the Edith
glasses to control a lot of weapons of
mass destruction that the villains want
to get their hands on it's all about the
legacy of Tony Stark both good and bad
his legacy as a hero with the Avengers
saving the world but also his legacy as
a weapons manufacturer
it was the same pair of students from
the first fake news broadcast from
spider-man homecoming Betty Brant
obviously big spider-man comic book
character she was briefly married to Ned
Leeds they go out during the course of
this movie even though they mostly play
it for comedy and that they break up by
the end of the movie her news broadcast
partner ron burgundy style jason iolo
who's just freaking out - the entire
broadcast is also a spider-man comic
book villain who used to bully Peter
Parker at Midtown high they tell the
story about everyone came back they're
calling it the blip and the reason why
they probably don't call it the snap is
because regular people on the street
wouldn't know all about the Infinity
Gauntlet the Infinity stones and how fan
snapped half of all life away than the
Avengers but their own Infinity Gauntlet
together in hoax snapped
everyone back really early on they
introduced the special homeless shelter
where they're giving the presentation
that Aunt May is running that's an
easter egg for feast fe AST in the
comics food emergency aid and shelter
those debuted during amazing spider-man
number 548 but you also remembered them
from the Marvel spider-man ps4 game
there's a crusher Hogan vs. bone saw
McGraw poster in the background that's
an easter egg for amazing fantasy number
15 but also the first tobey maguire
spider-man crusher hogan was the person
that he tested his strength against in
the comics and amazing fantasy number 15
Uncle Ben winds up dying after that you
remember that story in the version that
they did for Tobey Maguire's spider-man
origin story the name of the person that
he was fighting for money was bone saw
McGraw played by Macho Man Randy Savage
[Applause]
Peter winds up working with Nick Fury or
a person that he thinks is Nick Fury
during the movie the first time they
actually met in the comics was during
ultimate spider-man number 24 Nick Fury
shows up in his classroom and tells him
that when he turns 18 he'll be forced to
work for shield so the version in the
movie where he compels them into service
is pretty similar to the way that it
went down in the comics - [ __ ] please
you've been to space when they're on the
airplane there's an Easter Egg for a
whole bunch of movies that the world has
made to describe what's happened the
last couple of years they drop a couple
big comic book Easter eggs there's a
movie called the snap so there are some
people in Hollywood that are calling the
event the snap even though everyone else
really calls it the blip there's a movie
called finding Wakanda because now Black
Panther Wakanda has been revealed to the
world there's a hunting Hydra movie
which seems like it's based on the
events of Captain America Winter Soldier
there's a Nova movie with dr. Erik
Selvig so that's where he's been this
whole time Nova is a PBS science show
but Nova is also a very very big comic
book character the Kevin Feige has
teased they're developing a movie for
during Marvel phase 4 then there's a
movie about iron man called heart of
iron which is just a documentary about
the life of Tony Stark when they're
taking their boat to get to their hotel
in Venice in the canals there's an
easter egg in the background on this
boat that says ASM 212 that's the first
appearance of hydro-man in the comics
right before
or the big hydro ban attack the actual
hotel that they're staying at is Hotel
de Mateus J M DeMatteis has written a
lot of really big comic books spider-man
stories probably the most famous one
being Cravens last hunt
speaking of Kraven the hunter when Nick
Fury takes into his secret base
introduces into Mysterio for the first
time he introduces him to a character
named Dmitri who's based on dmitriy
smirnov in the comics aka
the chameleon but the chameleons
character is also the stepbrother of
Kraven the hunter in the comics when all
the students get back from the hydro-man
attack and they're freaking out about
what just happened flash drops a really
big comic book Easter Egg for hydro-man
seeing that a news blog is claiming that
the person who is hydro man was Morris
bench who fell off a ship and got into
an accident with an experimental
generator he's basically telling the
original comic book origin story for
hydro-man but obviously the elementals
are a very different spin on those
characters from the comics Mysterio
gives in this big explainer about the
multiverse he names our earth as six one
six and even though Mysterio is lying
during the movie technically he's not
lying about the existence of the
multiverse he's just lying about being
from another earth Mysterio is very much
from our earth because he used to work
with our version of Tony Stark the earth
that he says he comes from earth 8:33 is
actually spider UK's earth during the
spider-verse comics and even Peters new
costume the Steve Ditko looking costume
has some highlights that make it look a
little bit like spider UK's suit the
6-1-6 universe everyone knows is the
main comic book universe of the comics
which is a big term because the MCU up
to this point had believed to have been
in a slightly different version of the
universe so this is a huge change to
that Canon when the students are walking
around Venice there's a sign that says
Calle sterno which is meant to be a
street sign but it's also a reference to
comic book writer Roger stern who wrote
spider-man comics for a long time
starting with spectacular spider-man
number 43 there's street signs for a
whole bunch of other comic book writers
Calle slotto pretty obviously a
reference to Dan Slott Calle Ben D so
which is a reference to Brian Michael
Bendis Calle Michelini o which is a
reference to David Micheline who wrote
amazing spider-man around the venom
carnage Todd McFarlane era
Calle G Convio which is a
reference to Gerry Conway who wrote the
very famous story about gwen stacy dying
there was a reference during that during
the film when Mysteria holds up a
hologram of MJ on the eiffel tower sort
of their way of referencing the death of
Gwen Stacy from the comics during the
movie MJ wears a shirt with a tiger on
it so many tiger references you can
point to go get him tiger
face it tiger you just hit the jackpot
obviously she is meant to be the new
version of MJ albeit a very different
twist on the character than we've seen
before to Edith glasses that Ironman
winds up giving to spider-man stand for
even dead I'm the hero the all-black
stealth suit that he winds up getting
during the movie is an easter egg for
the Spider Man noir black suit which
debuted for the first time during
amazing spider-man number 650 during the
big molten man fight there's an easter
egg that says ASM two eight nine six
five which is an easter egg for the
first appearance of multi man in the
comics amazing spider-man number 28
during 1965 MJ figuring out the Peter
Parker was spider-man is also a comic
book Easter Egg for amazing spider-man
number 258 where the writer and the
artist reveal that Mary Jane had known
Peter Parker was spider-man for a long
time when Spiderman is making his
brand-new suit it's a big Easter Egg for
Ironman making his Iron Man suit during
the first Iron Man film oh I love Led
Zepplin and he plays ac/dc because
Ironman played ac/dc when he was making
Iron Man's stuff he puts his hand down
into the hologram the same way that Iron
Man put his hand down into the hologram
it's meant to be almost a shot-for-shot
mirror of that original Iron Man scene
he pulls up a display everything that
you have on spider-man and all these
suits flash on the screen most of them
big comic book Easter eggs you see the
classic red gold iron spider comic book
suit you see the velocity suit which is
actually a big suit during Marvel's
spider-man ps4 game then he combines a
lot of elements from his earlier
versions of the suit to make the
brand-new Steve Ditko read in black suit
at the very end of the movie in the
final post-credit scene
Talos reveals that there are Kree
sleeper cells on earth they could use
that for a big secret invasion twist in
a future Avengers movie there was a big
Avengers in Game Captain America Thor
hammer Easter Egg during that big drone
fight he picks up the arc reactor
wings it around then picks up part of a
car door to use as a shield in the exact
same motion the Captain America was
making when he was wielding Mjolnir
against Thanos during their first big
fight
spider-man losing his quote-unquote
Peter tingle during the movie is also a
bit of a reference to the spider-man No
More storyline that they did from the
comics during Tobey Maguire's spider-man
2 were for a very brief period during
the movie he kind of loses his abilities
because he's doubting himself so much
until he gets it back by the end of the
film the big final fight on London Tower
Bridge with him dancing through all the
drones trying to destroy them all also a
nice wink at Tobey Maguire final fight
with Green Goblin dancing through all of
his projectiles when he goes in the date
with MJ at the very end of the movie he
starts taking selfies of himself while
he's swinging around that's a bit of an
easter egg for Marvel's spider-man ps4
game where you can actually take selfies
during the game while you're swinging
around you also probably spotted the
very notable Green Goblin Easter Egg
when he's running across the rooftops
this rooftop here with the green rooftop
is actually the location of the
penthouse of Norman and Harry Osborn
during the Tobey Maguire era spider-man
movies spider-man one two and three so
very big Green Goblin Easter egg even
though Oscorp wasn't revealed at the end
of the film when he swings through the
giant Avengers tower that's been rebuilt
and redesigned there is a sign that
reads you won't believe what comes next
and there's like a one-two-three that's
more of a reference to Marvel phase four
it's not a Fantastic Four reference
because the numbers are building up to
the number four during the mid credit
scene it's revealed that J jonah Jameson
played by JK Simmons is back from the
Tobey Maguire era spider-man films so
that bringing him into Canon but instead
of a traditional newspaper he's more of
a video media person a la Alex Jones
conspiracy theorists talking out hit
pieces against spider-man because he got
this footage the fake footage from
Mysterio his contingency plan
quote-unquote spider-man's identity gets
outed on national television just like
it did during Marvel Civil War even
though during the comics he did it
himself
it's more of a teaser for spider-man's
villains so far calling open season on
and now that they know who he really is
like the scorpion in the original
spider-man homecoming post-credit scene
was
asking the vulture I hear you know who
spider-man really is then in the final
post-credits scene it's revealed the
Talos and his wife were masquerading as
Nick Fury and Maria hill the whole time
Nick Fury has been in a very Tahiti like
simulation on the sword Space Station
from the comics which seems like it's
going to be a really big thing during
Marvel phase 4 but there's a billion
more Easter eggs if you spotted any that
I didn't mention in the video just write
them in the comments below
and what will happen is I'll be doing
more spider-man far from home Marvel
phase 4 in Avengers endgame videos as we
go along they've been revealing a whole
bunch more deleted scenes and really
cool stuff I'll name a new giveaway
winner when I post a new Marvel video
click here for my spider-man far from
home post credit scene video and click
here for that brand new black Adams
Shazam seen from the Shazam movie thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]